Jean-Marie Le Guen le secrétaire d'État
chargé des relations avec le Parlement
et l'invité de preuve par trois bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être présent à ce
rendez-vous de Public Sénat avec
l'Agence France Presse représentait ce
soir par Karine Perret en partenariat
également avec Dailymotion et bien sûr
Perrine Tarnaud que l'on voit ici deux
publics Sénat sera également avec nous
tout à l'heure le débat tourne toujours
autour des réformes engagées par le
gouvernement Jean-Marie Le gueng engagé
ou promise d'ailleurs pour débloquer
l'économie française comme le disent
engagé déjà à bidou pour débloquer
l'économie en tous les cas comme le
disent à la fois le Premier ministre et
puis le ministre de l'Économie le débat
tourne aussi autour des difficultés de
Paris pour réduire son déficit et on le
sait Bruxelles France les sourcils nous
en parlerons donc tout à l'heure comme
nous évoquons également la nouvelle
donne pour l'exécutif un sénat désormais
à droite mais d'abord je n'oublie pas
Jean-Marie Le Guen que vous êtes
également médecin et il y a une
inquiétude dans notre pays concernant
Ebola que comptez-vous faire au
gouvernement pour RA une opinion on a vu
par exemple la peur irraisonnait mais
que l'on peut comprendre de parents
d'élèves à Boulogne-Billancourt alors
d'abord la première des choses c'est
évidemment d'avoir des dispositifs de
s'expliquer sur le dispositif puis
d'expliquer de quelle est la nature de
cette épidémie donc le virus Ébola est
un virus à l'évidence très dangereux
mortel dans bien des cas mais qui ne se
transmet que par un contact direct avec
les fluides d'un malade infecté ou d'une
personne morte d'ailleurs
justement donc si vous voulez
ce qui fait que dans des structures
africaines je vais commencer par là il
faut une petite minute pas plus mais
dans des structures africaines où on n'a
pas l'habitude où on a un deuil avec les
morts etc et malheureusement la culture
fait que il y a une capacité d'infection
qui qui se développe mais
théoriquement lorsque des soignants avec
du matériel sont en situation il n'y a
pas de risque
des fautes d'asepsie c'est-à-dire de
protection par rapport à un malade
infecté ou
insuffisamment de suspicion et donc ce
n'est pas parce qu'il y a une mutation
du virus et que tout d'un coup le virus
serait plus facilement transmissible bon
alors l'affaire de Boulogne-Billancourt
des parents
j'allais dire c'est une fausse alerte et
évidemment un peu juste parce que un
enfant semble-t-il rentrer de Guinée
bon on peut comprendre l'inquiétude des
gens mais il faut bien savoir que ça ne
s'attrape pas comme la grippe encore une
fois il faut des contacts avec des
fluides etc est-ce que vous pouvez dire
par exemple est-ce que nous sommes à
l'abri d'une épidémie parce que il y a
quelques jours des experts américains
ont modélisé en quelque sorte les
risques ils ont donné un pourcentage
pour la France et même une date
prévisible à la fin du mois d'octobre
est-ce qu'il faut craindre qu'ils disent
vrai non il peut y avoir des malades
infectés il peut y avoir des malades
d'infecter qui arrive sur le territoire
français comme sur n'importe quel
territoire européen ou américain mais
il y a toutes les dispositions c'est à
dire à la fois des services médicaux qui
sont tout à fait adaptés qui dès qu'un
premier cas et dépisté on y conduit le
malade et on le met sous quarantaine
sous protection et sous traitement sous
prise en charge médicale et deuxièmement
des systèmes qui sont des systèmes très
connus maintenant de de de si jamais
cette personne était passée comment
dirais-je un certain temps sur le
territoire national sans avoir bon assez
rapidement on sait comment contingenter
les personnes infectées on a un système
on organisation qui est bien protégée
voilà bon après il y a un autre mystère
qui est peu vraisemblable c'est la
mutation du virus c'est-à-dire que le
virus mutterait et deviendrait plus
transmissible mais entre le général oui
mais en règle générale si vous voulez il
y a une règle qui fait que plus un virus
est mortel moins il est transmissible
voilà et donc plus tous les
transmissible moins il est dangereux
Hollande a dit que la France était prête
à soigner tout malade absolument on a un
dispositif de prise en charge sanitaire
qui est sans doute un des meilleurs au
monde indiscutablement et d'un
savoir-faire à la fois des médecins des
pouvoirs publics
non mais la vigilance absolument pour ce
qui se passe d'abord en Afrique parce
que on pourrait on peut pas laisser
quand même l'Afrique à la dérive à la
fois parce que on est solidaire de des
populations par exemple totalement en
coupant les liaisons aériennes non c'est
une faute c'était une fausse bonne idée
parce que si vous voulez après les
choses d'abord il faut il faut lutter
contre la vraie transmission pas contre
les fausses pour transmission il faut
lutter y compris la base que fait la
France qui a envoyé Médecin sans
Frontières d'abord mais ensuite des
troupes des troupes excusez-moi mais
c'est des des systèmes de santé des
armées qui va là-bas qui est en pleine
forêt fait des des équatoriales fait des
choses très importantes
le chef de l'État c'est montrer
rassurant donc comme vous à l'instant
François Hollande encore une fois la
France pratiquement en Europe qui est la
première sur ce type de sujet précisé
on va parler tout à l'heure de
on va parler tout à l'heure de la France
qui n'est pas toujours le meilleur élève
de la classe on va nous dire ça et en
même temps quand il s'agit de sécurité
sanitaire ou de sécurité face au
terrorisme quand il s'agit de solidarité
la France elle est en première ligne
elle fait le travail j'aimerais bien que
l'Europe fasse ce genre de choses voilà
sois plus présent dans la coalition
internationale qui compte une certaine
de pays sanitaire
d'accord
ce qui se passe en ce moment en Irak et
en Syrie avec l'organisation Groupe
Islamique les djihadistes ont donc entré
dans la ville kurde de konobé en Syrie
malgré les Reds aériens
conduis notamment par les États-Unis en
priorité effectivement le président turc
Eric de Anne dit-il est-ce qu'il dit
d'évidence en plaidant pour une
opération terrestre qui montrerait là
son efficacité oui
indiscutablement les bombardements ne
suffiront pas attendez
mais nous avons toujours dit ça mais
nous pensons que c'est d'abord aux
Irakiens de régler cette question donc
notamment à la population kurde et à la
pop et au gouvernement et à l'armée
inquiète il s'agissant de cette ville
après il faut que les pays de la région
qui ont un intérêt direct dans la
sécurité directement menacée
j'allais dire contact physique puisque
cette ville elle est à la frontière de
la Turquie il faut que en liaison avec
le gouvernement irakien on peut imaginer
que un syndrome de pays et en
l'occurrence la Turquie se pose la
question d'une intervention au sol qui
est plus naturelle plus aisé et plus
vous dites que la Turquie effectivement
je pense que ça peut à partir du moment
où le gouvernement irakien et où il y
aurait en plus une prise en charge
juridique au plan de la communauté
internationale certaines conditions
peuvent être réunies pour que des forces
de la région interviennent sous un
contrôle des Nations Unies avec l'accord
du gouvernement irakien mais toujours
sans la France la France n'ira pas
combattre au sol d'abord parce qu'on est
sur le territoire syrien vous savez que
la France pour l'instant est sur le
territoire irakien et l'intervient par
avion par bombardement sur le territoire
irakien n'intervient pas sur le
territoire syrien au plan aérien
deuxièmement elle n'intervient pas à
terre d'accord on va revenir aux
questions françaises l'UMP maintenant
tous les tous ces grands leaders qui
sont engagés dans une compétition pour
2017 sans d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
il faudra réécrire la loi Taubira pour
sécuriser distillent Nicolas Sarkozy le
dit également maintenant la GPA et la
PMA est-ce que vous pensez de ce
scénario pour réaliser si j'ai pas
encore bien compris moi ni si tout se
sont prononcés il me semble que Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire a dit des déclarations
qui étaient tout à fait contraire en
disant qu'on ne reviendrait pas je
pensais à Nicolas Sarkozy à François
monsieur aujourd'hui c'est Monsieur le
Maire qui est candidat oppose le
secrétaire général de l'UMP je je suis
pas sûr que Monsieur Juppé et dit ça non
plus et je suis sûr que personne ne
reviendra sur cette loi j'en aucune
manière mais bien sûr parce que là du
principe même du mariage entre deux
personnes de même sexe on parle d'ajout
pour comme l'a dit l'ancien chef de
l'État sécurisé la PMA
expliqué qu'il allait mettre ça dans la
Constitution c'est une rigolade c'est
une rigolade on va pas mettre dans la
Constitution toutes les choses dont on a
peur que soi-même ne soit pas appliquée
et qu'on ne les appliquera pas donc tout
ça c'est
de la poudre aux yeux pour la manif pour
tous mais bien sûr il y a une course à
l'échalote pour récupérer ce noyau dur
de militants de droite et chaque
candidat de droite enfin pas tous
d'ailleurs mais certains plus que
d'autres à gauche qui s'élève contre la
GPA vous le savez contre les GPA bien
sûr mais personne n'a demandé
l'inscription dans la Constitution mais
voilà c'est c'est donc il y a pas besoin
d'en rajouter et personne ne dit
personne à gauche et personne ne s'en ne
peut dire qu'il y a dans la loi Taubira
une inclinaison vers la GPA c'est un
mensonge c'est un fantasme qui est donc
je veux dire ça ne touchera pas la
problématique de la réécriculture de la
loi et donc je dis il n'y aura pas de
réécriture de la loi et d'ailleurs les
Français ne veulent pas vous dites même
en cas d'alternance bien sûr
oui je l'affirme aujourd'hui absolument
j'aimerais que il y ait un engagement
pris par les candidats de droite en
disant qu'ils vont remettre en cause la
loi Taubira pour l'instant ils disent
pas qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
réécriture c'est quoi qu'on nous dit ce
qu'il ce dont il s'agit quel est
l'article qui veulent faire sauter
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent dire en tous
les cas à ce stade vous ne les croyez
pas un mot sur Nicolas Sarkozy tiens il
dit que les procédures judiciaires qui
se multiplient parce qu'une par jour en
ce moment on renforcé sa détermination
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne motivation effectivement pour lui
je pense que ça laisse à penser mais je
ne veux pas le croire que sa motivation
principale c'est régler des affaires
personnelles donc soit pour croît-il se
mettre à l'abri soit pour au contraire
essayer comme il le dit par ailleurs de
de sauver son honneur mais dans les deux
cas de figure c'est pas ça le sujet une
élection présidentielle c'est d'apporter
une réponse au pays c'est pas d'apporter
une réponse à soi-même donc je pense que
ces formules moi que j'ai entendu mon
étonné m'ont un peu choqué oui on va
parler dans un instant du budget
Jean-Marie Le Guen a des difficultés
pour trouver des économies et surtout
pour convaincre la Commission de
Bruxelles un mot sur les réformes qui
sont déjà engagés vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure on entend Manuel Valls à Londres
Emmanuel Macron dans un portrait que
dress de lui le New York Times évoqué
des sujets tabous jusque là le ministre
de l'économie qui dénonce l'amad
protection légale des travailleurs en
France le Premier ministre qui dit que
la question de l'assurance chômage doit
être posée on n'est plus dans on est
plus dans même pas dans le social
libéralisme là on est dans le non pas du
tout ce que ce qui est dit d'abord c'est
des propos qui sont indirectement
apporté là aussi j'allais dire ils ne
sont pas suffisamment précisés
du Premier ministre qui je vous dis qui
évoque la durée le montant des
animations chômage par exemple et qui
vendent le modèle britannique scandinave
en l'occurrence plutôt il était à
Londres oui oui mais le modèle
britannique n'est n'est pas exactement
le même c'est-à-dire que nous trouvons
et je pense que beaucoup de Français
trouvent que effectivement il y a par
exemple
tout un système de montant de
rémunération maintenue quelle que soit
les conditions qui posent un certain
nombre de questions ça doit faire partie
du débat ça sera dans le débat y compris
dans le débat social dans les mois qui
viennent puisqu'il y aura une
renégociation dans les mois qui viennent
pas entendre parler d'une plus grande
dégressivité des allocations chômage
Vous le savez mais peut-être mais comme
par ailleurs
peut-être un frein à la reprise du
travail oui puis par certains aspects il
est parce qu'il y a aussi on le sait des
gens qui justement ont un certain niveau
de rémunération de substitutions
par exemple et qui pour lequel on peut
se dire légitimement dans le système
actuel je peux attendre six mois un an
avant de rechercher un travail surtout
que
c'est une partie importante de son
programme exactement ce que vous dites
là mais écoutez c'est pas parce que on
dit qu'il faut par exemple des marges
pour les entreprises que c'est la gauche
le dit la droite le dit peut-être en
tout cas elle l'a pas fait nous on
essaye de poser raisonnablement les
choses sans défaire le modèle social ce
que j'entends de ce que disent les gens
de droite aujourd'hui plus que Monsieur
le Maire c'est on va faire 100 milliards
d'économies sans nous dire véritablement
et moi je sais comment on fait 100
milliards d'économistes vous allez
devoir déjà vous expliquer sur comment
on fait 21 milliards d'économies et 50
milliards jusqu'en 2017 puisqu'on va
parler du budget maintenant vous êtes
d'accord Jean-Marie Le Guen on va ouvrir
ce débat donc avec Karine Ferret de
l'Agence France Presse elle arrive juste
après cette présentation par Samia
dechir des chiffres clés et donc et le
premier d'entre eux bien ce sont ces
fameux 21 milliards d'euros d'économies
21 milliards d'euros d'économies en 2015
la France devra se serrer la ceinture
dans le projet de budget du gouvernement
l'effort sera répartie entre l'État à
hauteur de 7,7 milliards d'euros les
collectivités locales qui seront privées
de 3,7 milliards et la protection
sociale ou 9,6 milliards d'économies
sont annoncés l'exécutif estime avoir
fait un effort historique seulement pour
la droite le contenu est pas il est tout
à fait clair que le budget qui nous est
présenté ne respecte pas la trajectoire
pluriannuelle des finances publiques ne
respectent pas la parole de la France et
que les efforts de réduction de dépenses
prétendument fait au niveau de 21
milliards d'euros ne sont pas
suffisamment documentés pour qu'on
puisse y croire très remonter aussi les
frondeurs dénoncent au contraire une
austérité contre-productive qui risque
selon eux d'aggraver la récession
je pense que dans le projet de loi de
finances qu'on nous propose de voter la
semaine prochaine il y a une hérésie qui
est la baisse des notations de près de 4
milliards d'euros aux collectivités
locales qui sont le principal
investisseur public aujourd'hui
critiquer de toute part le budget 2015
risque en plus d'être rotoqué par la
Commission européenne car même avec 21
milliards d'économies le déficit
atteindra 4,3% du PIB bien au-delà des
3% exigées par Bruxelles impossible de
faire plus d'il exécutif dont la marge
de manœuvre est très réduite il faudrait
aller encore plus loin dans les
économies mais on voit bien qu'on arrive
aussi à une certaine limite et le danger
c'est si on va plus loin aussi on va
graver les effets récessifs de ces
politiques là donc on est effectivement
entre deux situations d'un côté
Bruxelles qui voudrait qu'on fasse plus
d'efforts et de l'autre côté l'économie
la situation économique qui
nécessiterait je dois faire au contraire
moins donc on trouvera le la ligne on
est vraiment sur une ligne de crête dans
lesquelles il est très difficile de
trouver de faire des bons choix le bras
de fer est déjà engagé
avec l'âme plus économie ironie du sort
s'est au français Pierre Moscovici
probable futur commissaire européen aux
finances qu'il reviendra de faire
appliquer les règles européennes à
l'Hexagone
sur cette question une très bonne
importance et autres polémique oui
plusieurs voix à Bruxelles disent que la
France va devoir revoir sa copie car le
déficit est trop élevé si demain vous
Bruxelles vous demande de faire 8
milliards d'euros d'économies en plus
comment est-ce que vous allez faire
d'abord Bruxelles peut faire des
commentaires elle ne fait pas le budget
en France le budget en France il est
voté par l'Assemblée nationale par le
Sénat par le Parlement oui mais la
Commission peut retoquer le budget elle
va l'examiner
et c'est pas au niveau de la commission
c'est au niveau du conseil donc si vous
voulez c'est dans un premier temps il y
a la commission qui fait des remarques
qui fait des critiques qui peut donc
s'exprimer ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs
de façon assez régulière parce que je
conteste en dehors de les phénomènes
dans une situation un peu particulière
vous avez une commission qui s'en va
c'est à dire qu'ils vont être ils seront
plus commissaires voilà Barroso monsieur
Barroso est un monsieur et sa commission
était très marquée j'allais dire sur une
ligne très libérale d'une part et assez
peu francophile d'autre part et s'en
allant étant d'ailleurs pas très content
de la manière dont on les a remerciés
peut-être qu'il y avait des raisons de
les remercier comme on les a remercier
ils font des remarques qui ne sont pas
très sympathiques potentiellement c'est
possible et bien nous allons discuter
sérieusement parce que nous avons des
arguments à faire valoir et on n'est pas
l'élève qui passe devant des
commissaires qui seront comme le mauvais
élève
ce genre d'attitude fait explique
d'ailleurs que il y aura pas d'éc permis
supplémentaires le budget va passer il
n'y a pas besoin de faire d'économie
dans les avoir un budget sérieux
je vous confirme que nous avons un
budget sérieux et que nous allons le
défendre sérieusement voilà et que nous
sommes prêts avec beaucoup de
capacité de dialogue à discuter des
questions qui nous seront posées et nous
apportons un certain nombre de réponses
mais on ne va pas se faire
morigéner par une commission dont le
substrat démocratique reste encore un
peu interrogatif pour quelques jours et
et après nous discuterons avec
l'ensemble des gens puisque nous sommes
dans une Union européenne nous avons et
c'est bien normal à présenter nos
éléments budgétaires nous le ferons mais
pas sur un mode d'un enfant qui se fait
gronder dans la nouvelle Commission
pardon Pierre Moscovici va peut-être
vouloir montrer son indépendance par
rapport à la France est-ce que la France
peut aller au clash avec la nouvelle
Commission
encore une fois nous sommes nous ne
pensons pas que nous allons au clash je
veux dire je nous le prenons pas pour
argent comptant si j'ose dire les
rumeurs qui existent aujourd'hui à
Bruxelles sur la manière dont on ferait
des commentaires sur notre budget
également donc en disant en disant
qu'ils se considéraient comme optimiste
mais
non seulement je dis que je suis
optimiste j'essaye de vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est un nous avons un bon
budget de nous allons argumenter trois
nous ne sommes pas en train de nous
faire noter ou de nous faire
morigéner je reprends ce terme par par
la commission sur par une commission
finissant
psychologique de la commission sortante
là qui n'aimait pas tellement la France
dites-vous est-ce que la nouvelle qui se
met en place effectivement
la commission sortante qui est là depuis
5 ans et donc responsable de la gestion
enfin en partie responsable de la
gestion de la crise après 2008 ça a été
et ça c'est
conçu ce que je vais vous dire c'est le
jugement du FMI de l'OCDE de la plupart
des grands économistes la manière dont
la zone euro a été gérée après la crise
de 2008 a été une véritable
erreur d'accord c'est à dire les
États-Unis
est-ce que la nouvelle peut être je peux
me permettre nous sommes extrêmement
impressionnés intellectuellement par
cette commission puisque elle a eu elle
a elle a mérité elle de recevoir les
félicitations vous notez mon ironie de
la part du FMI de l'OCDE et elle-même a
commencé voilà la commission est-ce que
on dit que certains dans
les salés peut-être voir de confirmer ne
risque peut-être un sentiment du complot
en disant bah c'est en fait le bras armé
de la toute la droite européenne contre
la France non c'est pas mon sentiment
mais je crois pas que ce soit du tout
l'état d'esprit d'ailleurs c'est pas
l'histoire de Monsieur Juncker et c'est
pas l'état d'esprit dans lequel on
aborde monsieur Barroso avait l'histoire
de cette commission était lourde je
viens d'en rappeler quelques éléments là
Monsieur Juncker il a fait pour tout ce
que nous avons entendu jusqu'à présent
monsieur Juncker était assez intéressant
les fameux 300 milliards
d'investissement il faut discuter etc et
nous pensons que la manière dont les
choses ont été faites jusqu'à présent
vont plutôt dans le bon sens la manière
dont la BCE évolue et la manière dont
finalement monsieur Juncker a l'air de
de considérer que il est plutôt bien que
la BCE évolue dans ce sens là tout ça
est assez positif donc mais par ailleurs
nous nous sommes contents de notre copie
avec l'idée d'une humilité nous allons
dialoguer oui vous avez parlé
d'investissement là je vous parle des
investissements en France les
collectivités territoriales on l'a vu
dans le reportage vont avoir leur part
d'économie à faire 3,7 milliards d'euros
d'économies Martin au Brise dit 13 ans
qui est pour le secteur de des
investissements le logement qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez il
y a un dialogue aujourd'hui entre le
groupe
majoritaire de la majorité sur cette
idée d'investissement il est évident que
du budget qui propose en amendement qui
permettrait aux collectivités locales de
récupérer de la TVA est-ce que vous le
soutiendrez cet amendement c'est une
piste qui est intéressante elle est
aujourd'hui examinée par le gouvernement
il est exact que les collectivités
territoriales sont dans un cycle nous
devons soutenir leur investissement en
même temps il est absolument évident que
il est légitime que les collectivités
territoriales participent à hauteur de
ce qu'elle pèse
dans le budget de l'ensemble de de la
collectivité publique et il est
important qu'elle puisse participer
voilà donc
il y a un dialogue qui était établi j'ai
bon espoir qu'il aboutissent à trouver
le réglage fin qui permettent
effectivement de faire des économies
d'abord sur le fonctionnement et qui ne
pénalise pas en priorité le
l'investissement vous craignez à nouveau
des débats houleux au moment du vote du
budget est-ce que vous
pouvez vous épargner le recours à
l'article 49-3
j'étais en réunion ce matin du groupe
socialiste alors je n'oublie pas les
radicaux les écologistes etc mais nous
avons eu
pas voter l'État le budget pardon à
l'état écoutez ça fait plusieurs fois ça
fait maintenant la cinquième ou la
sixième fois qui nous dit ça à chaque
fois il y a une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale pour voter les textes
budgétaires la confiance voilà donc je
suis pas plus que cela
je ne vois pas la nécessité a priori de
l'utiliser on verra s'il y avait une
attitude de la part de des uns ou des
autres qui veulent bloquer absolument le
débat on peut toujours se poser des
questions mais c'est pas je crois l'état
d'esprit dans lequel sont qui que ce
soit je pense qu'il y a aussi des leçons
qui ont été tirés de ces dernières
semaines et ces derniers mois je pense
qu'une certaine type d'attitude où on
voyait les socialistes se diviser entre
eux comme étant le premier spectacle des
plateaux de télévision et considéré
quand même par beaucoup d'électeurs et
compris de gauche par beaucoup de
militants du Parti socialiste comme
n'étant pas la voie à suivre je pense
que ça c'est limite donc ces limites
elles ont été intégrées donc on passe à
autre chose et en plus vous avez vu je
l'ai dit quand on est à 4,3 de déficits
budgétaires dire qu'on fait de
l'austérité c'est pas simple
justement
et c'est du quinquennat je comprends pas
bien ce qu'il veut dire par là je
comprends pas bien à moins qu'il ait
lui-même un objectif
surtout Carnot un objectif oui non non
je parle économique surtout que ça peut
de temps en temps on peut faire
essayons
aux élus de d'avoir des convictions sur
le fond et pas simplement des des
positions de de combat politique donc le
gouverne Arnaud lui-même a toujours été
à dans Montebourg a toujours été quand
il était ministre de l'Économie et bien
avant très soucieux des déficits publics
il a soutenu François Hollande dans la
primaire il savait et c'était aussi
parce que François Hollande avait dit
que son objectif c'était de ramener les
3% le déficit de ramener au 3 %. ce qui
ne sera pas aussi rapidement le cas
qu'on ne pouvait l'espérer en raison du
fait que la croissance européenne n'est
pas suffisamment bonne que la France ne
s'est pas suffisamment réformée tout ça
est exact et donc nous faisons un
un mixte en quelque sorte entre la
nécessité effectivement de diminuer la
dépense publique mais de le faire à un
rythme qui est pas trop brutal à un
moment où la consommation
l'investissement la consommation des
ménages est un des principaux moteurs de
l'activité économique si nous étouffions
par des prélèvements trop importants par
une diminution de la dépense publique
trop importante nous étoufferions la
croissance économique et quelque part on
aurait un déficit encore plus important
c'est-à-dire par exemple quand la droite
propose 100 milliards d'économies c'est
pas simplement la destruction d'un
modèle social c'est une erreur
économique parce que à vouloir trop
prélever de l'argent public brutalement
sur l'économie on aboutit à ce moment-là
à l'effet inverse de ce que l'on peut
constater c'est à dire un tel
ralentissement de la croissance que les
recettes de l'État ne rentrent plus et
donc à partir de là et bien vous avez
une augmentation du déficit sur la
partie famille des budgets justement le
gouvernement prévoit 700 millions
d'euros d'économies sur la famille
Marisol Touraine s'est dit ouverte à des
aménagements quand Christian et carte
dit que les 700 millions d'euros sont
immuables alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à des évolutions sur ces sujets
d'abord il faut rappeler que nous avons
augmenté les prestations familles depuis
deux ans d'un milliard d'euros
aujourd'hui nous les corrigeons à la
fois avec un effet d'enveloppe comme
vous dites c'est-à-dire 700 millions
parce qu'il faut 700 millions par
rapport à de la progression est-ce que
vous saurez d'accord pour changer des
choses sur le congé parental
j'allais vous répondre
je ne pense pas que nous reviendrons sur
la masse d'argent demandée il peut y
avoir des mouvements qui se font sur
quel est le sont les mesures les plus
appropriées pour obtenir un rendement
économique qui est celui qui dit
concrètement parler de rendement
c'est un débat parlementaire donc c'est
pas le ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement qui avant que le débat n'ait
eu lieu et en commission et le texte
présenter en conseil des ministres et le
débat à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale va dire hop la récréation est
terminée c'est moi qui décide
sous conditions de des allocations
en tout cas il y a pas d'esprit de
fermeture de la part du gouvernement à
partir du moment où il y a des grands
équilibres économiques qui sont
maintenus il y a une vraie réflexion
avec les parlementaires pour savoir ce
qui est le plus efficace
Aubry vous font peur
non pourquoi personne ne me fait peur ni
eux ni d'autres ils sont dans mon parti
et
au parti d'ailleurs
équilibre entre le PS et le voir les
écologistes et c'est déjà plus tout à
fait à l'intérieur du parti socialiste
ça donc dans un contenu
qui défendent des idées donc deux
étaient membres du gouvernement de
Jean-Marc Ayrault puis de Manuel Valls
et qui ont je le pense plutôt fait bien
leur travail on sait dans quelles
conditions ils sont ils ont quitté le
gouvernement c'était un peu pas
forcément leur volonté c'était un peu un
accident par des paroles malheureuses
bon donc je veux dire j'ai pas peur de
ce qu'ils peuvent dire même si je
comprends bien aussi qu'il souhaite
aujourd'hui s'affirmer ce qui est
parfaitement légitime merci beaucoup
Karine allez Perrine internautes
publiques scénariste maintenant pour
évoquer la nouvelle donne constituée par
l'élection d'un Sénat de droite
Jean-Marie Le Guen à ce stade on note
pas de volonté d'obstruction si ça peut
vous rassurer Louis Sibille
un Sénat à droite et si ce n'était pas
pour le gouvernement une site terrible
nouvelle pendant trois ans sa propre
majorité ne votait pas toutes les lois
et bien des signes indiquent que la fin
de cette parenthèse de gauche ne se
traduira pas par des crispations à
répétition Gérard Larcher l'a annoncé
dès le début de sa présidence à la
majorité je veux m'adresser pour lui
dire qu'une tâche latente
est une opposition constructive avec
pour boussole l'intérêt du pays en ces
temps de difficultés opposition
constructive la formule est lâcher de
quoi faire plaisir au centre qu'il avait
posé comme conditions à leur aliment à
l'UMP on va un sénat qui est vraiment
fasse des propositions va un sénat qui
construisent on va un sénat qui vote les
lois d'où elles viennent y compris du
gouvernement si elles vont dans le bon
sens parce que la situation de la France
exige aujourd'hui de pas être dans le
blocage tout de même le gouvernement
serait avisé de ne pas nourrir trop
d'illusions 2017 et dans toutes les
têtes et sur les textes jugés
fondamentaux l'opposition jouera son
rôle moi j'ai toujours dit qu'il n'aura
pas de réflexe pavloviens d'opposition
quand il faudra protéger les Français de
texte que nous jugeons toxiques et bien
nous opposerons quand le gouvernement
ouvrira le débat nous débattrons et nous
construirons
quand le Sénat veut grogner il s'est
grogné il est clair qu'il y a des sujets
sur lesquels on veut que le Sénat soit
respecté la réforme territoriale on ne
comprendrait pas qu'il y ait pas une
deuxième lecture c'est évident qu'il y a
quand même peu de chance que nous
votions le budget du gouvernement
socialiste il y a assez peu de chance
qu'un certain nombre de textes va se
fascinement dans le cadre des réformes
proposées si l'Assemblée nationale a de
toutes les façons le dernier mot reste à
savoir si le gouvernement s'autorisera à
ne pas tenir compte des avis et des
débats du Sénat alors on va voir
justement quel sort vous voulez réserver
à ce Sénat bonsoir père internaute
quand même quand on écoute les sénateurs
de droite qui viennent de s'exprimer
dans ce reportage ils sont plutôt de
bonne compositions ça va être plus
simple peut-être pour vous à gérer le
Sénat de droite que le Sénat de gauche
qui ne votait pas les textes
les élections ont eu lieu donc moi je
suis là pour constater qu'il y a une
nouvelle majorité au Sénat et je me
félicite de ces engagements je pense que
le pays a besoin aujourd'hui
à la fois d'une opposition constructive
et je dirais que le Sénat a besoin aussi
d'un travail constructif parce que
on le voit bien il y a depuis un certain
temps des interrogations d'ailleurs
depuis longtemps parce que générale de
Gaulle lui-même c'était déjà interrogé
sur la question du Sénat du Sénat voilà
et donc voilà c'est votre arme
attention c'est pas une arme du tout
c'est
pas du tout c'est pas une arme je pense
que les sénateurs en ont pris tout à
fait conscience et qui savent ce qu'ils
ont à faire c'est pas moi de leur dire
mais tout ça ce sont des choses
absolument évidentes le pays a besoin
d'une opposition constructive et non pas
d'une opposition posture on vient de
parler du budget à l'instant si vous
trouvez un seul endroit où la opposition
a soutenu la majorité dans une
diminution de la dépense vous me ferez
signe la dépense la défense non la
famille non
la police non la culture non les
collectivités territoriales la défense
je viens de le dire non etc donc si vous
voulez il y a 100 milliards de
d'économies à faire mais il y a pas un
endroit où la on nous a dit ce qu'il
fallait faire en diminution de dépenses
qui m'intéresserait dans l'opposition
constructive qui serait intéressant
surtout pour les Français c'est qu'on
nous dise et le Sénat va peut-être nous
le dire comment ils vont faire pour
faire ces économies de 100 milliards il
parlait de budget le fait que
ça c'est intéressant mais sur quel texte
vous pourriez trouver des axes de
concertation de conciliation avec la
droite est-ce que par exemple sur la
réforme territoriale qui va être l'axe
majeur ici de discussion de débat au
Sénat cet automne il peut y avoir une
voix pour le département pour le Sénat
et le département
d'abord sur le découpage des régions une
nouvelle carte des régions est-ce qu'il
y a une marge de manœuvre possible pour
le Sénat
juste pour rester juste pour finir sur
la réforme territoriale quelle va être
le calendrier parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'interrogations ici au Sénat est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une deuxième lecture
sur le découpage des régions et quand
exactement
il y avait des engagements sur lequel il
n'y aurait pas d'obstructions nous
étions favorables à une deuxième lecture
voilà
rapidement là dans les
semaines à venir à partir du moment où
il y a pas d'obstruction programmée on
en a des engagements d'un travail serein
raisonnable une semaine de travail et
tout ça est parfait
on vous comme tout à l'heure Claude
Bartolone dans un livre propose lui de
supprimer la fonction législative du
Sénat le BIC emerisme n'a plus lieu
d'être en France j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer je pense que le bicamérisme a
un sens je pense que le Sénat tel qu'il
est à du sens que il a pu à certaines
époques y compris sous des gouvernements
de gauche c'est à dire avec un sénat de
droite à apporter des choses qui étaient
tout à fait intéressantes encore faut-il
Barcelone mais c'est aussi l'opinion de
certains députés socialistes qui ont
publié dernièrement une tribune donc
c'est une idée qui circulait à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que ça vous
gêne vous qui êtes chargé de trouver un
équilibre entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat
a parlé de ça de supprimer le Sénat
c'était le général de Gaulle donc vous
voyez la gauche n'a pas le monopole des
idées d'une simplification ou d'une de
d'une marginale suppression le mot est
trop fort mais de de d'évolution forte
du Sénat donc la question elle est posée
pas par la gauche elle est posée
seulement et j'allais dire pas
principalement par la gauche elle est
posée mais ce n'est pas la position
actuelle pardon c'est quand même
essentiellement des propositions qui
viennent de la gauche aujourd'hui je ne
suis pas certain que avant la fin du
mandat vous ayez pas vous entendiez pas
autre chose de la part de la droite
elle a pour l'instant en tout cas dans
les tuyaux nous on regarde les
propositions qui viennent de la gauche
qui viennent notamment du président de
la République est-ce qu'il faut
supprimer diminuer pardon le nombre de
parlementaires
c'est ce que c'est une idée alors là qui
est largement partagée à gauche et à
droite le président de la République a
dit des choses en ce sens il me semble
que Monsieur Nicolas Sarkozy a dit
récemment des choses qui vont dans ce
sens il me semble que Monsieur Fillon a
dit des choses que l'on dans ce sens et
que peut faire le chef de l'État de
majorité des 3/5
rampant dans ce pays c'est-à-dire que en
fait non concitoyens ne se neuf pas le
matin en disant au fait réfléchissons
aux nouvelles institutions mais
objectivement quand vous voyez des
responsables politiques de gauche et de
droite beaucoup nous disent et beaucoup
se disent et peut-être que nous sommes
nombreux à nous le dire que le
fonctionnement du quinquennat des
élections législatives qui sont hop
juste après les élections
présidentielles certains s'interrogent
sur le BIC amerisme sur le bon etc sur
la problématique de la proportionnelle
toutes ces questions sans parler du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature du
droit de vote des immigrés etc etc
écouter François Hollande a dit qu'il
que lui il avait ses idées en tête qu'il
y réfléchissait
un débat politique c'est les
institutions ça peut demander à ce qui
est un certaines formes de mûrissement
quand même
qu'il y a une appropriation dans le
débat voilà on peut pas faire des
réformes qui seraient aussi importantes
et qui d'un coup ne correspondrait pas à
une maturation de l'esprit je suis pas
un consensus parce que je crois pas aux
consensus ni sur ce sujet ni sur
d'autres mais est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
un compromis est-ce que est-ce qu'il va
y avoir une maturation est-ce que est-ce
que les choses ont clairement on va dire
une option à une option du nombre de
parlementaires comme la proportionnel ça
suppose pas de modifications
constitutionnelle donc ça peut être une
loi qui va
il est utile de faire des lois qui
correspondent à un projet politique
global et qui sont acceptés dans la
société
à l'Assemblée nationale pour avoir
refusé d'appeler Sandrine Mazetier
madame la Présidente est-ce que c'est
une interprétation une interprétation de
règlement complètement disproportionnée
comme le dit Christian Jacob le patron
des députés UMPS alors là vraiment ma
fonction ministérielle m'interdit de
gérer dans les problèmes de règlement
interne de l'Assemblée c'est donc c'est
le gouvernement d'arrêt
c'est justement parce que c'est un
incident entre des parlementaires sur le
règlement de l'Assemblée nationale que
c'est un interfère en rien il y a eu là
pendant une demi-heure juste avant vous
des rappels au règlement un débat à
aucun moment le gouvernement n'est
rentré dans cette discussion voilà par
ailleurs
l'assemblée nationale un règlement voilà
elle juge comme elle l'entend la manière
dont elle fait appliquer son règlement
mais c'est très net ce n'est pas le
gouvernement n'a aucune autorité sur le
règlement de l'Assemblée ni à
l'Assemblée nationale ni au Sénat parce
que si je devais avoir aussi
un point de vue sur le règlement du sur
son application ça poserait d'autres
questions en tout cas on a pu entendre
dans les couleurs l'assemblée il vaut
mieux s'appeler tomate et nous que
Julien Aubert si on veut toucher ses
indemnités ça c'est en référence au
députés qui n'a pas démissionné qui ne
vient plus beaucoup à la journée
faire n'importe quel comparaison voilà
je le pense vraiment la démagogie à
certaines limites et qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du de la présence toujours alors
monsieur était venu je suis déjà exprimé
là-dessus
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que nous
y fassions la Constitution faite c'est
pas le gouvernement qui peut destituer
un parlementaire ça vous vous suggérez
pas que je puisse destituer des
parlementaires bon alors voilà donc la
question est bonne les Radicaux de
Gauche conseille nationale demain matin
faut-il ou non rester au gouvernement
c'est la question qui va être posée en
partie aux membres du Conseil national
du Parti radical de gauche
le sentiment il a subi il n'a pas été
réélu dans son département il y voit une
grande blessure et je le comprends
que si vous regarde de près je pense que
ce n'est pas totalement exact il a pu
avoir dans d'autres départements
des des dysfonctionnements à l'intérieur
de la gauche et des gens qui d'ailleurs
ont été critiqués par le Parti
socialiste voir exclu du Parti
socialiste qui ont pu contribuer à ce
qui est des parlementaires des des élus
radicaux qui ne soient pas élus et donc
je comprends il faut qu'il y ait des
mises au point mais je pense que
l'intérêt général fait que l'intérêt
général et l'intérêt bien compris de la
famille radicale c'est de rester
évidemment pas d'inquiéter non j'ai du
souci j'ai pas d'inquiétude j'ai du
souci des personnes j'ai des soucis du
respect des des personnes je comprends
qu'ils soient blessés voilà et ça me
soucie mais un des derniers alliés du
parc du gouvernement
sur la transition énergétique va
permettre de ressouder l'alliance
la journée parlementaire des vers
sénateurs et député
Ségolène Royal y est allé Claude
Bartolone est allé j'y suis allé nous
avons été très bien accueillis nous
avons eu un dialogue assez fructueux et
vous avez raison de dire que sur l'acte
majeur de ce quinquennat s'agissant des
problèmes j'allais dire de nature
écologique c'est la transition
énergétique j'ai bon espoir que les
Verts votent ce texte et d'ailleurs
d'autres à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
c'est un texte très important
et qui rassemble qui rassemble la gauche
mais qui rassemble y compris au-delà et
qui apaise c'est à dire dans ce pays
pour la société française et d'avenir
parce que il y a de l'emploi il y a de
l'énergie il y a plein de choses
positives Cécile Duflot a dit qu'elle
était plus socialiste c'est Manuel Valls
à faire c'est si elle veut prendre sa
carte elle vient il y a pas de problème
je l'ai déjà accueilli à Paris comme
candidate aux élections législatives
est-ce que vous regardez il a fallu
faire est-ce que vous grattez que le
Parti socialiste
moi je l'avais aidé ah vous l'aviez aidé
aujourd'hui parce que vous regrettez que
j'avais pris de la distance par rapport
à la fois un engagement qui était le
sien au moment où nous étions candidat
et puis par rapport à cette majorité je
lui ai dit elle le sais voilà maintenant
moi j'ai bon espoir encore une fois que
une fois qu'on savait le retour de la
droite on a malheureusement pas trop
parlé mais les programmes à 100
milliards d'euros etc et la fin de la
fonction publique les
39 heures payées 35
vous voyez qu'il y a des sources
d'économie
proposées vous voulez chercher tout à
l'heure
je cherche dans les textes blabla les
blabla de congrès je sais j'attends de
voir s'il le vote d'accord
merci Perrine la semaine prochaine
Perrine notre invité sera le nouveau
patron du groupe UMP au Sénat on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans le reportage
monsieur Retailleau merci à tous bonsoir
à très vite